Even pandas aren't really black and
white, they're actually colored.
Okay, usually it's like disgusting,
dirty brown, because they're,
they're really sloppy eaters.
Anyway so instead of clustering
in just the intensity space,
we could cluster in RGB space.
So this is notionally drawn here.
Right, where you can see that each point
now belongs to a different color
cluster and here they are.
And so you're grouping these
pixels based upon their color.
So now you're doing a quantization
in three dimensional space.
Here's a nice example of using
color instead of intensity
this original image here.
And you can see if you take
a look at sort of the, the,
the clustering based upon intensity
over here, it doesn't do a particularly
interesting job of segmenting
the cabbage from the broccoli
which is something you should always do
because you like one and not the other.
All right, but over here you can see
that based upon the different colors
you get the different segments.
And it's not rocket science, but
it's just this idea that you have some
things that have this similar intensity
but are very different in their chroma.
Right?
Their, their colors.
And we talked about color space,
last time, all right.
Notice, however, this pepper here and
this pepper there.
This system does not know at all
that those two peppers are distinct.
Right, because the only thing
it uses to create these clusters
is the distance in color space.
You might ask can I
do something smarter.
>> Can I do something smarter?
>> Thank you very much,
yes you can include not only
clustering in say intensity.
But you can also cluster,
so here we have, we have this
little part of the black ear and
this dark part of the eye, and you might
want them to be in separate clusters.
Well, how would you do that?
Very simple.
Instead of just clustering on intensity,
you would add the position as well.
So now, we have a three dimensional
space of intensity, no.
Intensity x and y or,
as shown here, intensity x and y.
Here we have the black pixels.
Together they're low in intensity but
separated in different areas in x and
y, and so you would get a different,
two different, clusters.
And of course.
If you've got intensity and you can do
position you have, can have color and
you can do position.
And the point here is that your
feature vector is getting longer,
looking for features that you'd all like
or, as many as possible, to be similar.
In order to say that everything
is in the same cluster.
So, notice that if I include the x and
y here, so, for example, these
two pixels, this green up in the top
left and the green in the bottom left.
They can't be clustered in the same
segments because they're different along
some dimension, namely the y dimension.
All right?
So that's, that's the utility
of adding these dimensions.